When we visited, I told you I had sore axillary node in my right arm and a swollen and I'm losing strength in any ideas.
I'm also trying to do the easy peasy coffee in of us three to four times a day, but I'm having a hard time holding it.
Does it do any good if you can't hold it?
So I'll address that first. So you're going to hold it for 30 seconds and you have to go let it out. Yes, you're still stimulating the vagal nerve.
So absolutely continue to do it. I mean, if you're just putting it in as just you can't hold it at all and it's just running out.
Even at that, you're still stimulation the vagal nerve.
So I would say, you know, as long as it's too uncomfortable, I would keep it up.
As far as the axillary lymph node, the, the, the, if you're losing strength, it must be putting pressure on one of the nerves.
So I would, you know, I know you said, I think you said you were using ice on it, I would try to you, I would try a couple different techniques.
So if you use ice on something to decrease swelling, if you have swelling around the node, then typically that is what's recommended from a physical therapy standpoint.
However, some people react differently to ice and it doesn't work well for them.
So if you try alternating hot and cold, like do two minutes of ice and then take it off and put a hot pack on there for two minutes and alternate back and forth.
You might be able to get a puppy action. That's the idea of that. And you could help get moved that out of there.
I would also try some just motion exercises to get flowage and contraction of muscles to get movement of fluid through there.
And just getting some motion in there might be able to get some fluid out of there so there will take some pressure off the nerve.
Because if you're getting weak this and that orbits, I would think that has to do with their pressure.
So anything you can do to try to decrease inflammation of that area, I think would be best.